you and your family and all of your
fellow Americans are now more than 21
trillion dollars in debt the u.s. passed
that threshold last week as we reported
Deirdre bolton of the Fox Business
Network tells us what all this means the
US government just hit a record but not
one with bragging rights we are in debt
a lot of debt the US government spends
much more than it takes in during
President Obama's tenure the national
debt nearly doubled Democrats and
Republicans agreed to government
bailouts of numerous industries after
the 2008 financial crisis this past year
there were a dozen large scale storms
combined the cost of responding and
rebuilding was about 200 billion dollars
while few citizens find fault with the
reasoning the money is still spent
recently President Trump asked for more
money for defense supporting the fight
against Isis and funding the Department
of Veterans Affairs and other agencies
some politicians say there is a limit to
what the country can afford the greatest
threat to our nation is we ourselves
it's our inability to deal with the
fiscal issues that we as a nation have
the Director of National Intelligence
dan coates has said that Washington's
lack of fiscal discipline undermines
national security President Trump is not
worried about the national debt sources
say he believes the American economy
will grow and compensate for increased
spending in February President Trump
signed a law that suspends the debt
ceiling allowing the US government to
borrow as much as it needs to fund the
activities approved by Congress until
March of next year some economists say
that the US can increase its debt
indefinitely but then we would be an
unchartered territory Brett
Thank You Deirdre thank you